[Musique]
sayid arrivera t bonds là
tu ferais mieux de prendre un peu d love
tu va m'expliquer ce que je dois faire
dans ce cas pas de pluie ça peut parfois
tout change et occupe toi de ton volant
nous enquêtons sur un raison de voiture
volée dans toute l'europe
et j'entends toujours là non jour après
jour au lieu de deux frères pouvoir
faire
demi frère tu sais que tu voudras où on
est mais si j'ai essayé de me convaincre
il n'a rien voulu savoir parfois on
contre une équipe va l'expliquer ni vaut
mieux avoir de problème dans ce cas ce
n'est pas nous contrarier nos alors
comme ça vous êtes frère n'a pas grandi
ensemble au fait qu'ils commandent moi
désolé on pouvait pas savoir que c'était
pas de voiture on peut faire quelque
chose pour vous avec ce club
vous dites que vous voulez vous aller
cette ferrari 62 directement sous son
nez vous avez une semaine il va nous
falloir l'équipe pour réussir un coup
pareil ils veulent mouiller à m
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
les autres familles
[Musique]
quelques uns des scènes attendre à cake
quelqu'un de l'intérieur lorraine
il y à un agent double qui opèrent à
berlin
pour et qui traque les agents
ne faites confiance à personne votre
contact et david percival a été votre
première impression horrible perla à ses
propres règles
je n'ai absolument aucune confiance en
soi
on m'avait envoyé dans un sac à merde
mais vous le saviez déjà janvier
[Musique]
bouclez votre ceinture qui voter
[Applaudissements]
le temps nous est compté
[Musique]
je suis un passionné
à
[Musique]
je n'en mange pas de noter des champions
je suis juste
[Musique]
c'est la seule chose facile
naoto kan
le gamin vous deviez mouche nature et
peybernes unis ld nous avons tous les
stocks par mois
[Musique]
les gamins deuxième en expédiant le pire
et
de minuit à 8 heures jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
m
rien
alors que jan était un enfant comme les
autres
mais un jour il découvre la vérité sur
ses origines et décide de partir à
l'aventuré et guerre laventure
vous êtes qui je sais pas comment on
peut le dire mais je suis ton père mon
père celle dé foot qu'est ce qui pouvait
m'arriver de pire ailleurs est ce que je
vais devenir comme ça et j'ai dû
remarquer des changements comme les
cheveux qui pousse de 10 cm dans la nuit
ou les pieds qui sont super ceux des
chaussures et c'est pas tout tu peux
aussi parler aux animaux la femme les
gars khalid de rencontrer pas si c'est
dû fuir parce qu'on voulait ma peau
version ne reculeront devant rien pour
avoir ce qu'ils veulent
thomas a besoin de nous notre seule
chance de russe et s'y met tous ensemble
je suis toujours prête en avant les
super les professionnels
[Musique]
si la méfiance et big foot junior où je
suis les marques de ces zus
[Musique]
iniesta carles des moudjahidate flybuy
lors du second single so perfect
timberlake et mila kunis a mal à la mode
et au delà
[Musique]
vainqueur 6-3 contre auxerre
et
gabriel
non
on y montre
[Musique]